ladies and gentlemen
please stow all electronics fasten your
seat belts and place your tray tables in
the full upright and locked position
because it's going to get weird
i'm nervous all right hey
as the tcp protocol goes or in some
circles hey hey girl
girl our network's flaky
but here's my data so store it maybe
my name is kyle kingsbury you might know
me as afer online
and i'm here to talk to you about
network partitions
what are our petitions anyway we just
don't know
science tells us that networks that are
asynchronous are allowed to drop
to delay to duplicate or to reorder your
packets
messages in any way they like now in
practice iep networks do all four of
these things but tcp means that you
won't see any duplicates or reorders in
the context of a single connection
that guarantee doesn't apply if you ever
lose the con the contact of the tcp
session have to reinitiate or if you
have multiple sessions going
simultaneously
so you can still see some reordering or
duplicate problems depending on your
retry
and path behavior the really critical
thing to notice is that delays and drops
you really can't tell them apart they're
the same thing and in fact we have a
proof that it's impossible to build
what's called a perfect eventual failure
detector in asynchronous systems
you can't tell if the other node is
actually dead or just ignoring you
what i want to impress upon you is that
this is not just a theoretical construct
partitions are actually a real problem
microsoft for example says they see 40.8
link failures per day
ranging from five minutes to a week in
the case of their you know long distance
uh
lines and moreover their redundancy you
know having multiple paths for the same
links only improves the odds of packet
loss by 43
so even though they've got good hardware
good you know control change management
uh and redundancy they're still not able
to eliminate the problem of network
partitions
google says that in a cluster's typical
first year five racks will go wonky and
say 50
packet loss they'll see eight network
maintenance per year uh
which might result in 30 minutes of
packet loss on half of those and they'll
see three router failures where they
have to redirect traffic away from the
data center entirely
sherpa dynamo and chubby all cite
network petitions as a driving factor
either in their initial design or in
their uh you know sort of evolution of
the system
uh chubby for example you know it's a
strongly consistent system uh they
actually
pull some interesting tricks with with
clocks uh but they still say that
network outages are a
source of major uh you know sources of
downtime for their system
practically speaking you can see network
predictions due to all sorts of problems
ranging from garbage collection right if
your jvm pauses it can't respond to
messages that's a delay
uh network maintenance either planned or
unplanned segfaults and crashes
both in your routers and in your
software faulty knicks
broadcom for example is notorious for
dropping packets under high low they had
a nick which took flow control packets
in on on like a nick backplane and
spewed out the flow control for the
interface to every single interface on
the switch
so the defense essentially turned the
you know slowed down you're going too
fast message
into a ddos
you can't make this stuff up uh bridge
loops spanning tree problems uh your
remote hands are of course remote and
handy
uh the cloud is a nebulous thing uh if
you've been following aws for example
last week there was a network
event um and then of course if you have
wind links you have to wear a backhoe
squirrels hunters sharks the rest of
that
so these are a few of the companies that
have written up post mortems recently
about their network petition behavior uh
notably github
had a really spectacular one where they
lost uh
they lost synchronization between a pair
of mysql
nodes backed by a drbd synced file
system
and ended up with a split brain
phenomenon and one of the consequences
that besides downtime
was that the the data stored in one of
the mysql primaries was inconsistent
with data stored in another data store
and that actually caused them to show
private repository information to a
handful of incorrect users
not the end of the world right very
small probabilities but the consequences
can be severe
so in short we don't live on planet
terra no matter how much i may wish it
uh
and our distributed systems are going to
fail and when they fail
they're not going to fail simply they're
not just going to turn off they're going
to fail in this kind of hiccupy
weird stilted way where maybe parts of
the system work and parts don't
so i've been trying to explore these
failure modes for the last
year or so really and i've come up with
some interesting results
this project called jepson after that
you know famous
pop star from canada uh is a system
like sort of a little network in a box
you set up five nodes
fully connected and they run a database
and then you set up five clients outside
that database cluster and each client
typically talks to one of the nodes
the clients cooperate to perform some
operations like writing a bunch of data
and then if they uh if they get a
response it says successful they record
that
if they get a response that's like nope
sorry couldn't store your data correctly
they record that too
and then at the end of the process you
tally up all the logs from all the nodes
and try to figure out what should have
happened and you compare that to what
the database
actually has so by comparing the
expected and the actual state you could
figure out whether or not certain
properties were held
such as linearizability
in this case during the test we
initiated a network partition separating
the network
into two components a minority component
smaller than one-half
and a majority component bigger than
one-half
the cap theorem tells us that there are
sort of two opposing poles of maximally
achievable safety properties
you can either have serializability
where your system
orders all of its transactions in a nice
uh you know
non-interleaving way or you can have
availability where every non-failing
node responds to all requests
successfully
now both ap and cp systems can remain
fully available in this case and it's
important to remember there's a whole
continuum right you could do any number
of things in between
certain operations could be cp or ap you
could offer
linearizability over a subset of the
database but not over the whole thing
but but no matter what the case in this
particular failure mode
all systems can preserve serializability
uh
the cpu systems need to have a majority
or primary node so it might force
re-election or
for quorum to shift the ap nodes don't
really care for them logically it's just
the same as a regular day
since in an ap system there typically
isn't uh any
defined ordering for the operations now
in practice ap systems do a lot of
interesting things around failover
setting up fallback vnodes and whatnot
but but logically speaking the
consistency model is the same
so back at recon i did another talk in
which i explored a couple databases
i looked at single server postgres which
is naturally a single point of failure
but it's also consistent
redis on the other hand goes into split
brain mode during partition
and drops all the data written to one
side of it so you can't really trust
redis and this is a this is a
consequence of asynchronous
uh replication models um you can't
ever fail over in an asynchronously
replicated system without having the
potential to lose some data
mongodb every single consistency level
led to lost data
this is partly the cause of weak
defaults because the
the old defaults were to write without
even checking if your write succeeded
the new defaults are to write and then
see if it worked on one node
but that's not strong enough if you want
serializability you actually have to
talk to a majority of nodes
and the majority setting actually had a
bug which caused you to consider
failed network connections i.e timeouts
and partitions
uh as successful responses for the
purposes of get last error
that's now fixed react has another weak
default
last right wins essentially means that
you drop rights no matter what even if
you use an external lock service
even if you use primary even if you use
primary write all there is no
combination of consistency uh
you know systems which can provide you
with a way to safely write to react
using last right wins you just you
cannot do it
the only cases where safety's last right
wins are where data is immutable
or otherwise you know it's safe to drop
something given that you've got
mostly the most recent copy in short you
want to use crdts and we'll get into
that later
so that was then this is me now
uh we're going to be talking about some
new databases uh mew keeper
meow db catka and cat sandra starting
with zookeeper
zookeeper is a paxis-like protocol it's
called zab and it offers linearizable
rights
uh and it does that by having majorities
with leaders it looks a little bit like
paxos the president but has different
guarantees
the behavior is nice uh it detects
predictions quickly
rights will immediately fail and
majority components should continue
after the election takes over
um as a consequence it's only partly
available and this is exactly what we
expect from a cp system
i want to demonstrate that so i'm going
to fire up a
zookeeper client here and it's going to
talk to my five zookeeper nodes
and it takes a little bit for the client
to initialize what this client is going
to do
is they're going to write a list of
integers to a single z node
which is a sort of unit of storage in in
zookeeper
and they're going to then read and write
in a compare and set loop
trying to do atomic updates you know
adding a single element each time
now we've caused a partition you'll
notice that rights have stopped this is
because the cluster doesn't have
consensus anymore
the old leader which was on n1 is being
forced to fail over to n3
or n4n5 anyone on the majority side
basically
and at that point you'll notice that our
rights which had taken place
uh they might they've got a higher
latency right they were waiting for that
election to take place
but now three of the rights from the
three clients talking the majority
can succeed and then two of the rights
from the minority side must stop
and that'll persist for a while we'll
see the the latencies fall off
over time until finally only the
uh the minority side of the cluster is
being forced to wait for
time out because it can't reach
consensus um so this is a well-behaved
system we recover it
uh at the end of the day we did 500
writes and
out of 401 sorry 400 one of those were
acknowledged and successful and
all of those 401 rights were present in
the final set
uh in addition we actually found one
right which supposedly failed but was in
fact present
this is a typical consequence for cp
systems which don't do say extend
three-phase commit
so boring
this is exactly what you want your
latencies are bounded
they fall off quickly for the duration
of a partition as long as a majority is
intact you can keep working
so that's great right for 50 of the time
if it's partitioned you might see 78
uh you know availability no false
positives this is
perfect right zookeeper is the only
system i've tested so far which does cp
correctly
in short use zookeeper uh because the
linearizability properties is to keep
are a little bit complicated it
guarantees that the sessions are
linearizable but you don't have any
guarantees about
what the other node sessions have seen
so they'll see all the rights in order
but one of them might be much further
behind that means that you should use
existing recipes like those in curator
to do things like leader election
and uh um you know
other zookeepery things
technical terms neodb
this is a fun one nudity came to my
attention because of this amazing post
to a mailing list
by a man named mr jim starkey who is a
famous database engineer
very important man he he writes that the
cap conjecture he is convinced is false
and can be proven false
the cap conjecture has been a
theoretical millstone around the neck of
all acid systems
good riddance this is the first wooden
stake for the heart of the nosql
movement
there are more coming and it goes on in
this vein for a while
uh the marketing claims from
adb you know i'm sort of looking into
this trying to figure out what they
actually do
this is the database he founded by the
way uh the marketing claim say that
partition resistance includes the
possibility for a subset
of the chorus to sing on the new debut
refutes the cap theorem
cool story bro uh
i want that database right this would
make everybody's lives amazing
so you start looking into it it's an sql
database
it's distributed but it's not sharded so
the whole db lives in every node but it
is replicated for purposes of
performance and for redundancy
uh it uses these monotonic uh sort of
leaders over ensembles of what they call
atoms
which are sort of the granular units of
concurrency in the system
and at various points in the
documentation it claims to be any or
none of c
a and p depending on what combination of
the
commit protocol and other things you're
using
what happens in practice with this cap
theorem refuting database is you can do
things like try to drop a table
but you can't drop the table because the
table's identity sequence doesn't exist
so you say okay i'll create the entity
sequence we can't create the
non-existent identity sequence because
the non-existent entity sequence
already exists
okay so you nuke the database from
scratch and start over
this is easy to do because neodb does
not bring its crash storage back online
when you restart a node so if you
restart it it starts with the fresh copy
no data
this is desired behavior for their
customers uh apparently
no i'm serious so there are race
conditions in join if you join nodes in
the wrong order you'll end up with
like split brain but it's quiet so like
the nodes will be running
you know completely isolated copies of
the database with some data that doesn't
have anything to do with what their
peers have
uh you can join a node to itself uh
you can i mean it's just it's a
difficult db to work with operationally
like it's
hard to start this thing reliably so i
can't actually demo it for you because
it takes too long to start
um but if you do start it what you'll
see during a failure is something like
uh duplicate value in unique index
sequences primary key you'll see end of
stream euf broken pipe connection reset
indefinite latency
what indefinite
indefinite if you if you let neodb run
during a partition it will block as long
as the partition lasts uh
right here i'm giving up after 65
seconds because that's when it started
to run out of ram
but it will keep going and i haven't
found an upper bound and it will
actually continue to block well after
the partition resolves
so in this case this is 1500 seconds
after the end of the partition
and our latencies are still as high as
45
yeah 45 seconds um so
there's a there's a silver side to this
this cloud which is that uh
out of all the acknowledged rights all
of them were present in the final set so
it was
it was uh consistent it's actually not
serializable i think it's snapshot
isolated but i haven't figured out how
to test
exactly the difference but it does
appear to
at the strongest consistency levels live
up to its name
uh the the problem actually is the
latency
because during the partition absolutely
nothing can take place
you kind of have to ask yourself when
was the last time you ever waited five
minutes for database query to come back
right is this actually available uh
what's
what's done here is you just wait until
the partition is over and then replay
all your operations everything is sort
of backed up in some massive queue
and then at the end of the partition you
can finally start to apply that q and
then you have to work out all the
conflicts and that's why it chokes
for so long after the partition occurs
um but the new db engineers are actually
really cool people uh
they don't believe mr starkey uh and and
they they understand these tradeoffs
right so they're working hard on it um
they're trying to build in license
detection there's actually a beta in the
in the current build but it's not
production ready yet uh
and they're also addressing all these
bugs so hopefully those will go away
soon
long story short it's still a young
database uh but if you're interested in
distributed sql systems it is
possibly worth a try um you just might
want to wait a little bit for a
temperature
kafka um kafka is one of my favorite
systems it's
it's a messaging system so it does these
durable
cues which are these like immutable logs
of messages and then it has a system
where you can consume those
immutable logs using zookeeper so you
get ordering
you get durability uh you get you get
sort of linear
shard ability um and it's an extremely
fast on any given node
uh so typically you can saturate a wire
actually with with kafka messages
uh so i i love this system and has this
new feature in a way called replication
so you go and look at the slides and you
ask how does this work
and it tells you that kafka replication
picks ca consistency and availability
well i've i've told you earlier that uh
out of the of the cap
three you can have cp or ap but you
can't have ca
why is that well because ca systems only
exist if partitions never occur
this is very explicit in the gilbert and
lynch paper uh if a partition does occur
and i've asserted that it can
then you have to suddenly worry about
which one of those two you're gonna pick
so anytime somebody tells you they've
chosen ca
all i've done is said i haven't
considered what happens during partition
typically ca systems tend to fail into
one of these categories or neither of
them
when they're actually subject to a
failure
so the reason they could uca is because
they're in a data center and we know
data centers are magical
and uh they have strong consistency and
it's bite-wise identical
let's see how uh they do this by having
an instinct replica set and this is
actually a really it's
a nice simple design it's easy to
understand you you have a set of
replicas which are responsible for the
data
and your leader writes out the the write
to all replicas
and then once all the replicas have
acknowledged it then the leader
considers it committed
if a node is isolated then the instant
replica set will shrink so now we only
have to replicate to two out of the
three so that allows us to tolerate node
failure
i'm going to go ahead and run our kafka
cluster here
the interesting thing that they claim is
that with f nodes you can tolerate
f minus one failures and the way they do
that is by allowing the instant replica
set to shrink to exactly one node
the liter alone so we're waiting right
now
for our kafka cluster to wake
up hopefully this will work i've
discovered that if i run on the laptop
there's some timing abnormalities with
battery that like
mess with things oh look at that that's
terrible
luckily i've got slides um so
what happens uh in the event of a a
leader disappearing
is that you've got an empty instinct
replica set right so there's no safe
path forward
but the show has to go on you can't just
throw up your hands and declare the
databases over
so instead you promote one of the stale
nodes
so you might take one of the one of the
remaining nodes that are available
promote it to the leader and whatever
stale copy it's got that's now the
authoritative state of the universe
and it begins replicating it to its
peers
the old leader when it comes back online
sees the new leader
throws away its old state and recovers
the leader's rights
so this means that there's some fraction
of the of the rights time flows down in
this picture
initially you're able to replicate from
the leader then you can't replicate
because the prediction happens and the
instant replica set shrinks to the
leader alone
rights are acknowledged only to the
leader and then when the new leader
comes to power it's not causally
connected to those old rights
so when it comes back together those
rights are actually lost
in practice you'll see a brief network
latency hiccup
when kafka is doing the failover and
then everything will appear to be
fine but these these rights are actually
the the walking dead
if you if you suffer a partition you'll
see another little network hiccup and
then suddenly
half of your rights are gone uh and the
interesting thing is that because
in a well-balanced cluster every node in
your kafka system is going to be a
leader for something
if this happens to any node you're gonna
see data loss
what do i mean specifically by happens
uh
you need two failures to occur first the
instant graphic asset has to shrink so
we've got some stale node to exist
and then all the instant replica set
nodes have to lose the zookeeper
connection which forces the uh you know
handoff to
the new leader um so if you have a
leader
who is partitioned away from the rest of
the kafka cluster and then the leader
you know its disk crashes or it loses
power or
the zookeeper cluster gets messed up or
somebody like administrator says oh
that's funny i guess i'll just reboot
the node
all of these things would force
re-election and cause data loss
so what do you do to improve this
replication model i mean how could you
do better
the the problem is that we acknowledge
data that was written only to one node
and that's a little bit dangerous
so instead what you want to do is choose
a majority of nodes and what that means
is that if you ever
fail if you lose you know coherence uh
you've got a majority of nodes to pick
from the chances you ending up with a
single node failure that can lose data
are lower
so it shifts the failure earlier in the
in the sort of timeline of the system
you're more likely to fail
or to stop accepting rights but you're
less likely to destroy data
and we know this is true because of math
which tells us the majority quorums are
provably optimal for non-dominated
codery consensus felt tolerance
so long story short look for majorities
as a general rule of thumb
not all systems have to have them but
they're a good way to do uh
quorums and consensus among small groups
of nodes
uh the kafka team at linkedin you know
really really smart people they're
dealing with
incredible constraints and incredible
scale and they've got good reasons to do
what they did
um so they're having to balance you know
the sort of
strong correctness with performance
constraints and that means that
the system is still evolving since this
is still beta right you should expect to
see changes and
in fact my information is probably
already out of date it's about two weeks
old at this point
um so if present you should turn on any
stronger safety rules for
craft consistency uh you might want to
roll your own replication
if if this doesn't provide satisfactory
properties
um and finally you know what i
trust the engineers right like they're
they're smart this is still early
they're gonna get it right moving on to
cassandra
uh everybody asked for this one after
the last talk and it's it's gonna be a
big one
so cassandra's a dynamo system first off
that means it has a hash ring
so you have keys and the keys get hashed
into some space
and you carve up the space into chunks
you hand the chunks to different nodes
use a hinted handoff quorums active
anti-entropy to repair
looks just like react or or voldemort or
dynamo
but unlike the dynamo paper it doesn't
use vector clocks
it uses last right winds only now if you
saw the previous talk you're probably
throwing up your hands at this point
but in fact sally it depends you can't
safely change the last right wins
register
and by safe i mean you want to guarantee
that your right is
causally connected to a future state
that your right isn't just thrown away
entirely
because in a last right win system if
you are adding a b and c to a set
maybe first you start with a two nodes
concurrently read a and b
and then one of them writes a b the
other one writes ac
last right wins is going to pick one of
those rights to succeed and the other
one will just disappear it's like it
never even happened
so if there's a case where you don't
want to lose your rights you can't use
last right winds
now vector clocks allow you to identify
that causal isolation and give you both
copies back
so you'd see a b and ac and it would be
your responsibility to merge them
into a single value like abc that merge
function has to obey some properties
uh properties which are a little bit
non-intuitive honestly it has to be
associative
commutative and item potent and if you
do those three things you get this
structure
a semi-lattice called a convergent
replicated data type
and this is a nice type of consensus
that you can get for ap systems
but i can't actually get into the theory
here because we're out of time
the long story is that cassandra chose
early in its evolution not to use vector
clocks and did that for performance
reasons it didn't want to have to do a
read before every write
so they can go twice as fast in terms of
network round trips
uh but as a side effect of that there's
no safe way to modify a selling
cassandra
some people say you can with an external
lock service and just like with react
they're wrong
um if you write uh using like quorum
r plus w and uh and you know external
lock service so your rights never
interleave you might see like 44 of your
rights acknowledged but only
but out of those roughly you know a
third of them would just be thrown away
um so this is particularly interesting
in light of the cassandra documentation
which like on the front page says that
it can be tuned to give you strong
consistency in the cap sense
uh i don't know where that idea comes
from
so you can't do changes but but you
could do something different
in cassandra you actually can write
really efficiently very
large numbers of cells to a given row
so what you do when you're making
changes to data structure is you write
everything as a new change
you build an immutable log of operations
such that every operation has its own
cell
and then when you read you get back all
of those cells
so we add cell a cell b cell c
and then when you do a read you have to
merge those cells together somehow
so you apply a merge function this
should look familiar
and then you have to do some garbage
collection eventually you might have to
like clean up old elements of your set
uh vector clocks you know handle that
for you but we're we're getting a
performance advantage here right they're
not having to do round trips
but the the critical thing is that when
you're doing
reads in cassandra that merge function
has no no well-defined order
right you don't know when new values are
going to show up in the past and you
don't know what the interleaving is
going to be it might not be stable
so because of that your merge function
still has to be commutative you still
have to do all the same reasoning about
out of order operations that you do with
reocc the difference is that your merge
function is expressed over rows instead
of over a single object
what this means is that riyak and
cassandra have essentially equivalent
consistency semantics
react is slightly stronger but it's uh
you know the performance characteristics
are so widely different that it's not
really worth comparing them
react for example can't handle anywhere
near 10th or 100th of the right lobe the
cassandra can
so if you're doing like log structure
data analytics um
you know large olap cubing cassandra
might make a lot of sense
if you're working with data structures
where you want to like deeply nest a
single c or dtt and have guarantees with
the atomistic rights of that crdt
then it makes sense to use reac let's go
ahead and try it
oh we're not going to try that one cool
so uh what happens if you actually write
to a
cassandra data structure they have this
thing called cql which is a new query
language and one of the things in cql
is collections and the collections are
basically
these limited crdts so you can do your
rights
to say a cql set or cql list and
every one of them even in the presence
of a partition will succeed latencies
would be phenomenally low
again this is because you're you're
writing everything uh to distinct
cells at the end of that you might see
that all 100
of them were acknowledged rights and
that every one of those knowledge rights
succeeded
this is a great phenomenon right it's
not ordered it's not it's not consistent
in a capped sense
but it is safe it's a different kind of
consistency property
so the cql collections are pretty
intolerant and highly available
but the semantics are a little bit
subtle in particular you might have to
worry about deletions
for example if you delete from a set the
way it does that is by writing a
tombstone and tombstone actually has
some time information encoded in it so
you can actually delete writes from the
future
which which is what you might expect if
you used uh
like any any sort of eventually
consistent system like the deletes
typically
are really complicated you either have
to include a vector clock in the delete
record or timestamp and
and the timestamp version you know means
you can delete future writes
uh there's a different kind of set you
can use called an observed remove set
which actually doesn't have this problem
you can only delete things that you've
seen
but cassandra doesn't use that another
data structure cassandra doesn't use is
pn counters which allows you to do safe
counters in a very intolerant way
instead because of twitter and or
politics we have something else
uh which will under over count by
basically 100 during partition
so if your prediction lasts for 50 of
the time you might see
like either 50 out of 100 rights or 150
out of 100 rights
depending on what you want again not the
end of the world they're very fast right
it could be totally appropriate for use
case
isolation from a transactional asset
standpoint the data stack stocks say
atomic row operations give cassandra
transactional atomic isolated and
durable support
we know what atomic means atomic means
that if i write x and y together i'm
going to see
nothing or x and y i'll never read just
x but what does isolated mean
like show of hands how many people in
the audience know what isolation means
like ken cool uh you're i'm not one of
those people uh
but it turns out that mathematicians do
know what it means um
we've got a bunch of different behaviors
and these are a little bit arbitrary and
complicated
there's things like p4 which is lost
update phenomenon three which is phantom
rights fuzzy reads dirty reads these
don't really apply to cassandra because
there's no notion of a transactional
read than commit
but but there is a different sort of
even more basic consistency
for isolation called p0 that's a
phenomenon called dirty right
where your rights are interleaved and
intuitively it seems like interleaved
rights would be bad imagine that you
wrote one
one and two two to a single record
uh so one goes to the first cell two
goes to the first cell
two goes to the second cell one goes to
the second cell because your rights are
interleaved
out of one one and two two you might get
2 1.
so this is this is an inconsistent like
a dirty uh sort of read you don't want
to see just part of your transaction at
the end of the day
what you want is for them to appear to
apply you know as
isolated chunks this is so important
that berenson and his friends at
microsoft in their paper say that ansi
sql isolation
should require p0 for all isolation
levels not supporting p0 means you can't
claim to be
serializable can't claim to be snapshot
isolated can't claim to be cursor stable
can't claim to be any of the anti-sql
isolation levels you can't claim to be
isolated
but it does claim to be isolated uh
cassandra 1-1 row level updates are now
made in isolation it guarantees that if
you update both login and password in
the same update then no concurrent read
may see only a partial update
or another part of the documentation uh
transactional atomic isolated and
durable support in the acid sense
uh hacker news comments everybody thinks
that if you write x and y together
you'll see x and y together
you won't cassandra actually allows p0
and more uh isolation abnormalities
and the reason is that in cassandra the
right order doesn't actually
matter last right wins is the only thing
that matters for conflict resolution and
last rate wins takes place on a per-cell
basis so
if you're looking at two cells and they
have equal time stamps
you've gotta pick one somehow and that
that choice should be stable
so you choose the one that has the
bigger value lexicographically perhaps
so if i write one negative one in one
transaction and two negative two in a
different write
the first cell is going to say that two
is bigger than one and pick two
the second cell is going to say negative
one is bigger than negative two and pick
negative one
so now i've derived a case where the two
don't line up i should have seen
one negative one or two negative two but
instead i've got two negative one
in short this is p zero does this
actually happen
well that's a little bit complicated uh
i'm gonna go ahead and run an isolation
test
in this test our cassandra cluster is
going to take a bunch of writes which
look like
1 minus 1 2 minus 2 that sort of thing
and it's going to verify
that at the end of the day out of all
the it's not going to verify
take a look for logs
so wait for that to come up so which
with the rights are gonna
the rights are gonna be writing one
negative one two negative two three
negative three et cetera and they're all
gonna just be contending on
on a similar set of rows and in this
system we're actually gonna write
uh every row twice so there's gonna be
one opportunity for a conflict per
row and that row is going to be written
to with a mean uh
latency between the rights of 100
milliseconds uniformly distributed from
0 to 200.
see if it's woken up yet
man live demos
wow okay cool i'll show you the results
instead
uh the answer is that it depends if you
do some math to figure out how likely
time stamp conflicts are
you could find out that the probability
of seeing a conflict in any given read
assuming you're doing your rights of
assange distributed to a single cell
varies with the frequency of the rights
so if you do one right per second
probability of reading a conflict in any
given read is 10 to the minus seventh
if you do tend to the six writes per
second it's basically one and two reads
you'll be corrupt
uh if you do 10 writes per second to a
cell and you read it once per second
in any given day you've got about a one
in three chance of seeing corrupt data
this is not this is not a bad result by
the way right if you're updating that
record all the time
uh chances are the data doesn't actually
matter that much
right like any given value it will be
immediately succeeded by some valid
value
so it could be you just show some
inconsistent data briefly but if it's
mission critical that isolation actually
hold this doesn't work
if you do two writes per row and they're
separated by mean light and save 100
milliseconds as poisson processes
the probability of seeing a corrupt row
is basically 10 to the minus sixth
but this is actually a theoretical limit
right we've just done the math about how
often
you know microsecond timestamps can
collide
if you actually do this in practice at
least with the java driver
you'll find that 1 in 250 rows is
corrupt
so 1 or 250 is a lot bigger than 10 to
the minus 6th
what happened the reason for this
is that somewhere in the guts of either
cassandra or the drivers i haven't
figured out where exactly
something is trying to figure out the
millisecond timestamp to use for the
right
and it does that by taking sorry
microsecond timestamp it does that by
taking the millisecond counter or the
millisecond clock
in java and tacking on three zeros to
the end and calling it good
so the chances of seeing corrupt data
may much may be actually much higher
than you expected
long story short there is no
case in which you can actually provide
real isolation with cassandra like you
only want isolation if you're doing your
rights at the same time if you're doing
at the same time they're going to
eventually hit the same timestamp
so your guarantees are probabilistic at
best just keep that in mind
if you do want transactions however if
you want to do your operations in an
isolated way cassandra has introduced
this really cool feature
called lightweight transactions
transactions offer linearizable
consistency
according to docs and they do this by
doing paxis rounds
so you uh you set up a pack test quorum
over the owners of that that given part
of the hash ring
and you do your uh your reads and writes
inside of these these uh
you know compare and set loops
essentially so your comparing set gives
you this nice
correctly ordered series of operations
first thing you'll notice if you try
this is the java driver doesn't support
them
the only support is actually in the
python driver
and only then via the thrift interface
so it's a little bit awkward
so you get in touch with data stacks and
they help you out they you know
add the right contents to the driver and
you give that a shot
uh maybe my cassandra nodes will
actually cooperate today
let's try some transactions
work the first thing you'll notice when
you run cassandra transactions in 2o is
deadlocks
and by deadlocks i mean permanent
deadlocks i mean if you push more than
like 10 transactions through jepson on a
cassandra cluster
it'll lock up the cluster permanently
you can't do any more transactions on it
uh until you go and you clear the system
paxos table which you know was unsafe
man i don't know why this is not working
all right well
someday
if you go and you get a copy of
cassandra from git
that has this bug fixed and then you can
actually run the transactions but
they're not linearizable
um in fact there's two bugs in the
current taxes transaction library that i
found last week and those are 60 12 and
60 13.
basically you can accept two distinct
values for an even paxis round
and a failed proposal can still succeed
in a later round
that means that out of a given series of
cassandra transactions you might see
five percent of them succeed
the reason that so few of them succeed
that the taxes transactions are so
unavailable is because they're really
slow
it takes four network round trips to do
an operation um now you can make this
faster by using uh fast pax hosts or
packages of presidents etc
but as it stands you know you really
can't push
more than i don't know 50 or so
transactions per second through my
cluster
without it basically falling over
you'll also notice that out of those
transactions four percent of them might
be
lost so that's a catastrophic result
right like
you're you're never supposed to have
paxos lose your data um
and then you'll see some false negatives
too so this is this is
uh interesting right like this is a
production release uh the advertising
all over the place claims it offers
these linearizable properties but it
seems like
nobody actually checked to see if they
worked um
but at the same time you know like a
couple days after i found this and
reported to datastax
this thing comes out and it says uh
apache cassandra's development of
lightweight transactions in cql are true
industry firsts
i i don't know what this means actually
because like chubby uh
libpaxos uh wandisco you know plus
zookeeper and all the other consistency
systems
i just i have a really hard time
reconciling the advertising with the
reality
so what does this all mean right i know
i've ragged a lot on cassandra and these
various uh you know inconsistencies
but the fact of the matter is that it's
a very good database and it's a very
mature database
for the subset of functionality that's
not new um you can use it as
an ap store so anywhere where your
rights can be commutative you can use
crdts
you can either write your own crdts on
top of the the rows
or you can use the cql collections which
are really well formulated
the new data structure layouts in in cql
are much more intuitive much easier to
understand
than the old system uh keep in mind that
isolation and atomicity guarantees on
rights are probabilistic at best
if you rely on them you need to run the
probabilities and verify that they hold
uh and you should probably avoid
transactions for the foreseeable future
um those two bugs 60 12 and 60 13 plus
the deadlock bug
uh we're all found with like you know an
hour's testing with uh with jepson
those are now fixed but i'm not
convinced that
the testing culture at data stacks has
gotten to the point where i
would necessarily rely on the
advertising time and what works
so use cassandra use it for ap stuff
logging storage it's terrific at that to
recap
jepson tells you about one system um and
and by system i actually include the
clients right because the clients
and the application semantics and the
network and the failure topology and the
servers and the versions all this stuff
interacts right
even even individual jepson runs the
same software
can vary greatly because you might hit
its particular timing abnormality which
causes a failure
so that means that i can't tell you
about your systems you shouldn't take
these results to mean that oh
you know kafka is bad or cassandra's bad
it's it's instead
here's a particular interesting way that
a system
could fall apart and you can use these
same techniques to measure your own
systems
ultimately you'll have to generalize
these particular stories into you know
what matters for you you should go back
to your architecture diagrams
and ask questions like what happens if
the node disappears
what happens if our nodes uh pause or
hiccup for three minutes and we can't
get anything to them
um github for example had a network
event which caused
packets to get delayed for five minutes
so they had a stoneth cluster
right let's shoot the other node in the
head uh each one declared the other one
unavailable and issued a shoot the other
node and the head message and
fired their bullets basically uh but the
bullets were suspended in midair because
of the network petition
and they were held in the buffers of the
switches for five minutes then the
network petition you know sorts itself
out i think it was something with mlag
and uh and the you know bullets slam
into both servers simultaneously and
they collapsed the ground in a pool of
data
um i i may be getting the details of
this wrong but you should read the post
mortem because it's just it's amazing uh
worry about that uh you need to ask
careful questions about clocks right
if you rely on clocks and you consider
them unique do you have sufficient
resolution for the right volume you're
planning to do
if clocks are far in the future you know
decades or or minutes
uh is that a problem if you have a leap
second like we all saw with that um you
know uh leappocalypse last year
uh you know you can see the same second
repeated twice and if you're subtracting
seconds you might see zeros just
be concerned about those sorts of things
right wherever possible try to rely on
logical clocks on the consistency of
your data and your operation flow
instead of the
the wall time ask questions like
what happens if a network delivers a
message late or what if there's no
majority
what if what if you do have a majority
but it's on the opposite side or it
keeps shifting
what happens if you can see two
different nodes they can't see each
other this happens in ec2 all the time
and what i'm really driving at here you
need to define the the liveness
guarantees and the safety guarantees
that your system actually needs
because ultimately losing data can be
okay inconsistency can be okay
right cassandra can be a phenomenal
place to store log-oriented data
especially data which is slightly noisy
because the inconsistencies are never
going to matter so ultimately you have
to
balance the complexity and the
difficulty of writing correct system and
the performance costs
with the correctness
finally what i want to emphasize right
no matter what trade-off you choose no
matter what system you're writing
write a test program have it make some
reads make some rights
log what happens and then measure that
your model of the system aligns with the
system actually does cause
failures while you're running that test
program kill nodes use ip tables to cut
off nodes from each other
skew clocks right ntp is not reliable
finally see what comes out i think you
might be surprised
i'm indebted to the individuals at data
stacks at new odb
and at linkedin for their assistance in
understanding and debugging these
systems
in commutative order jonathan ellis rick
branson
eric linvall left side patrick mcfaden
alexa ishenko seth proctor
duke armonis nejar nakede jun rao kelly
summers
drew blas michael klishnin camille
fournier j kreps joseph blomstead
peter bayless thank you very much